blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
welcome everybody you may or may not
have heard this because
uh you've probably grown tired of yet
another
challenge to the affordable care act but
obamacare
which is the same thing as the aca
remember obamacare has survived
another challenge and this one in the
supreme court via
a seven to two decision which we're
going to look at in a moment
you know um at this point it's time to
stop
even thinking about obamacare as this
additional thing on our
health care system you know it's it's
been 11 years
uh the fundamentals of obamacare are
just now
part of the not that great health care
system that we have
in the united states and increasingly
i mean at this point dozens and dozens
of house votes when republicans
controlled the house to try to
undo it various different legal and
constitutional challenges
donald trump and four years of trying to
gut it despite the fact that he had
nothing
sensible or reasonable to replace it
with
we just now have our health care system
and it includes some obamacare
provisions
and we now need to move forward from
where we are but
there are many who don't want to accept
that and there are many who want to
continue pretending that
there is still this appendage that is
obamacare which could just be
clipped off very very easily it's just
part of our system at this point in time
let's look at some of the reporting on
this from cnbc
the supreme court ruled on thursday
against
texas and other republican-led states
seeking to strike down obamacare in the
law's latest test
before the nation's highest court the
top court voted seven to two
to reverse an appeals court ruling that
had struck down the law's individual
mandate provision
that is the provision that donald trump
very aggressively tried to attack
because if you get rid of that
you are really doing significant damage
to the way obamacare works
uh justice stephen breyer who authored
the opinion of the court
said that texas and the other states
that challenged the law
failed to show that they were harmed by
it in legal terms the states failed to
demonstrate that they had
standing neither the individual nor the
state plaintiffs
have shown that the injury they will
suffer or have suffered
is fairly traceable to the allegedly
unlawful conduct
of which they complain the decision is a
major victory for the legislation
which former president barack obama
signed in 2010 it's a crucial element of
the nation's health care
system joe biden has vowed to expand
its reach the decision marks the third
time that obamacare has survived the
challenge before the supreme court
defenders of the law worried that the
panel which is now a 6-3
republican-appointed majority would
scrap the legislation which has long
been criticized by
conservatives chuck schumer said each
time in each arena
the affordable care act has prevailed
going on to say let me say definitively
the affordable care act has won the
supreme court has ruled
the aca is here to stay and now we're
going to try to make it bigger and
better
what a day what is most frustrating to
me about this
is that obamacare did good things but
it's really no
incredible victory it's not
uh god's gift since sliced bread or
whatever other
metaphors and analogies you want me to
uh embarrassingly mix together
um we really you know i've said before
medicare for all is not the only way
and i've spoken recently to other people
on the left who have a similar
perspective
if you look at what germany has done
with a multi-payer system
if you set up a system where the health
insurance companies
exist but they must be non-profits and
have to compete
with a government plan if you want to
do a combination system like
france has or in amsterdam
i'm sorry in uh in in the netherlands in
holland
um taxes are uh higher than in the
united states
and people pay a small fee for a
comprehensive health care system at
least my friend who works in in
amsterdam does
but overall it's way cheaper than in the
united states and
you have access and quality is quite
good there are other
ways that we can get everybody coverage
that is good
um so this is not about it has to be
medicare for all which i would be very
much
open to this is about the fact that 11
years later
we're still arguing about something that
is
number one not a miraculously great
thing
although it does good things and number
two
is not radical the fact that in other
countries there are
so many phases beyond where we are and
we're at
half the country or at least half the
elected officials
want to get rid of obamacare the other
half want to keep it
joe biden wants a public option but
there's real questions about whether
there's any practical way
that it's actually going to be made a
reality anytime soon which would be a
great failing for joe biden
to be absolutely and completely clear
it's humiliating that this is even the
conversation that's happening
in the united states when you look at
every other country that's at our level
of wealth
and our level of development and so you
know when you ask me
what is the most disgusting thing about
this is it disgusting
that republicans when they had the house
had like 60-something votes to try to
repeal obamacare even though it was
going to go nowhere
yes that's disgusting uh is it
disgusting that republicans continue
to um try to work within the legal
system at different
state level courts all the way up to the
supreme court and that trump made it
such a priority
during his presidency to get rid of
obamacare even though he had nothing
sensible to replace it with
all of that stuff is disgusting there's
no question about it whatsoever
but the really crazy part to me is that
this is so milk toast this is so listen
it's
good healthcare.gov it's good that it
was created
keeping people to age 20 up to 26 on
parent insurance that's good
pre-existing conditions it's good
it's not that those things aren't good
it's crazy that
those things even needed to be done in
2010 but the fact that 11 years have
gone by
and other than some really small tweaks
mostly because of coronavirus
we are not anywhere beyond obamacare
and there are still efforts being made
to get rid of it
that's actually the disgusting part that
it's something so milk toast and
unremarkable so
obamacare survived again in the supreme
court great
uh now maybe we can find something else
to actually get done
uh over this 11-year period during which
it's been basically just
uh fending off attacks on obamacare
from republicans i don't know i don't
know we'll follow
and see what happens there are 21
republicans who voted against
awarding medals to the police officers
in washington d.c
speaking of fighting off attacks the the
police officers in washington dc
who quite literally fought off attacks
from trump rioters on january 6th the
house
overwhelmingly passed legislation to
award the congressional gold medal to
the police officers
who defended the u.s capitol during the
january sixth riots
lawmakers approved the award by a vote
of
406 to 21. but wait a second
sir 21 no votes where did those come
from
the 21 no votes were of course all
republicans
and all supporters of donald trump some
have tried as newsweek rights to
downplay what happened on january 6th
others have been previously linked to q
anon conspiracy theories
um congressman thomas massey of kentucky
says that this could have an effect on
the hundreds of suspects
who have been charged in connection with
the events of january 6th
massey's saying i think if we call that
an insurrection
it could have a bearing on their case
that i don't think would be good
if they just wanted to give the police
recognition
they could have done it without trying
to make it partisan making the case that
if you just wanted to give medals but
not refer to what happened as an
insurrection maybe
massey would have gone for it but when
you call it an insurrection you're
politicizing radical republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor-green of
georgia
said she voted against it because it
referred to the capital as a quote
temple
she also said i wouldn't call it an
insurrection congressman scott perry of
pennsylvania said it's all politics it's
all garbage
so here's the list of the 21 that voted
against it many of these will not
surprise you
andy biggs lauren beaubert is of course
on the list
michael cloud andrew clyde warren
davidson
matt gates and louis gomer no surprise
to see them on the list
bob goode paul gosar is a disgusting
radical
of course marjorie taylor greene andy
harris
jody heiss is on the list he is
absolutely vile and disgusting we've
talked about him recently
thomas massey who i just quoted mary
miller barry moore ralph norman
uh scott perry john rose matt rosendale
chip roy
and greg stouby of florida
a number of lawmakers expressed outrage
at representatives who voted against
it adam kinzinger tweeted how can you
vote no
to this is beyond me then again
denying an insurrection is as well to
the brave capital and dc metropd
thank you to the 21 who voted against
this
they will continue to defend your right
to vote no
anyway you know for me what is uh
i hate when we look at a political issue
or an issue that could be a political
issue and then realize it's just
posturing for optics
i i hate that because i find it to be a
form of grifting it's claiming to care
about something when you really don't
it's a version of playing a character
publicly that is not really who you are
they back the blue they support the
police
the thin blue line all of this different
stuff and then
all of a sudden hey let's award these
officers for what they did it's the same
very police that
you claim defending against any
of reduction in funding is your
patriotic duty let's let's award them oh
no no
no no why well the word insurrection was
in the bill
the word temple was in the bill and this
goes back to
what is fundamentally republican support
of
institutions that they deem worthy to
their political world view
without really giving you know what
about the individuals
and i go back again to this example of
the iraq war when george w bush
was president it was all about support
the troops support the troops support
the troops
and when people on the left like me said
hey you know what
if we send troops into harm's way
because of a lie about who actually
attacked us on 911 and we sent him to
iraq
that's not supporting the troops that's
blindly supporting a neoconservative
republican president
who wants to finish what he sees as the
job his father george h.w bush left
undone in the early 90s that's not
supporting the troops
i was called unpatriotic so it's not
about support the troops as individuals
get them health care when they come back
and make sure we treat ptsd seriously as
opposed to some kind of
character flaw it's about support the
troops means
hope that they go and kill a bunch of
people and turn a blind eye to what a
republican president wants that's what
they mean
and it's very similar with what's going
on with support the police here's some
police you can support well no we mean
just funding departments so they can get
tanks and shoulder-mounted rpgs
these these are individuals we don't
really care about them that is
at its core what this is really about
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter
at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinkist
and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show is made possible
by viewers like you who
sign up for membership at joinpakman.com
consider yourself
invited to grab a membership on my
website
let's hear from some people in the
audience why don't we we've done well
with it the last few weeks we take calls
via discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's start today
with a connor from atlanta georgia
connor you're on the air hey david
yes hey um so uh
been watching your show now for about a
year um
i uh funny enough first time i actually
saw you was um
on jessie lee peterson show okay um
and uh i've been kind of doing some soul
searching
um i'm 19 i
voted for the first time uh back in
november
[Music]
um and i've been doing some soul
searching in regards to politics i don't
i really cuz because i would usually say
that i um was a i guess an independent
uh a centrist um whatever you would want
to
label someone who doesn't really
associate themselves with
um a political party or say i've never
called myself a liberal i've never
called myself conservative
i think um because they're because i
guess if i could maybe give you an
example like i'm not
really big into um
like the the online left
politics like with the cancel culture
and
and things like that and i'm not i'm not
when it comes to like i guess uh
uh republicans or conservatives i i'm
not really
um i don't really believe in like the
so-called
embracing tradition uh quote unquote um
so connor what's an ex what's an example
of like a cancellation that happened
that you disagree with
um i guess i i wasn't a big fan of
uh when gina carano
got fired from the mandalorian for her
comments
uh because i i think that there were
people who probably did much worse
things that still have careers like say
um
uh james gunn when he uh 10 years about
a decade ago when he made all those
nasty tweets and he was fired then he
got rehired and
and um i just that's one thing i say i
disagree with i was
not at all not a fan of trump at all
okay
so connor did you did you have a
question today just because we've got a
bunch of people who want to get on
i think i have a sense now of your
politics but did you have a question
um sure um okay okay i
do have a question okay about palestine
and israel
um why do you i don't know if you think
this but
at least i got this impression from
someone i know someone who watches your
show
um he mentioned how you maybe believe
that it should be under uh
control of two um
belief systems or ideologies rather than
one what should be under the control
uh the the palestine and israel uh issue
going on i i believe
in a two-state solution that maybe
that's what your friend meant
yes yes yes that's what i meant yeah why
do you believe that as as
as opposed to a one-state solution i
think there is absolutely
no chance that a one-state solution has
even the
possibility of bringing anybody even to
the table
as difficult as some people say it would
be to negotiate a two-state solution
that would be acceptable to both sides
there will never even be a negotiation
about a one-state solution so i see it
merely as something that gets it
it's guaranteed to get us nowhere as
opposed to maybe gets us nowhere
okay i see i see all right well i
appreciate it david thank you
all right connor thank you there's
connor from atlanta let's go
next to brett from indianapolis brett
you were on the air
good to hear from you again pleasure
yeah so i i'm gonna be quick
um so i wanted to ask you do you think
you know who i refuse to say his name he
just makes me so mad
do you think he will go down as the
number one worst president in history or
do you think at least the top five worst
well the top five worst out of how many
if this country lasts another 5 000
years
it you know we could have a lot of
really bad presence i just think there's
no way to answer those questions you
know what what we can say is
donald trump represented a huge
inflection point in the
debasement of the office of the
presidency
he is the worst president in recent
political history
but any kind of you know long-term
pronouncements who
who knows it's very hard to make those
predictions and not particularly useful
either
right i mean i feel like you know
you know a person like hitler he was
certainly studied
a lot and there's certainly some changes
that were made
after you know germany because of what
happened to hitler and i feel like
he could have some repercussions as to
you know changes made because of his
presidency
yeah we will see we will see there
should be consequences both for trump
and
i mean listen one of the things we
learned under trump was the safeguards
we thought we had in place in case like
a really horrible person got elected
many of those safeguards clearly aren't
strong enough because donald trump so
far has skated with no consequences but
we'll see hopefully there will be
consequences brett
yeah and do you uh feel that it is
important that we
give him media attention because i had a
german friend so
i'll sum up the story he said why do you
guys still give trump attention
yeah i've talked about this before he is
for now
the most prominent republican and still
the leader of the republican party which
is one of only two major parties in the
u.s
so to just ignore him for the sake of
ignoring him
doesn't really make sense given that he
does have you know
the vast majority of his 74 million
voters still
follow the guy and would follow him to
another party or vote for him again so
he's relevant in american politics and i
know you can say well he's only relevant
because people talk about him
he still has 74 million followers that's
the reality
yeah so my german friend was like well
why don't you guys just ignore him and i
said
how did it work out for you guys when
you ignored hitler
yeah fair fair fair i i like that i like
where you're going with that brett
yeah all right good talking to you again
okay thanks brett brett from
indianapolis getting right to it
fantastic let's go next
to how about roman from pittsburgh
roman you're on the air hi can you hear
me
yes i can um so um
i mostly wanted to talk about the new
york election that's happening
um i was very interested in the change
in the voting policies that they're
enacting um i think that actually has a
lot of potential
nationally as well to um cause some
actual
um like moderation and the candidates
that kind of have a chance of getting
elected
sorry are you talking about the new york
city mayoral race
yes oh and what what change did they
make i've not been following it or maybe
i've forgotten
um they transferred to like um like a
standard transferable vote or like a
single transferable vote okay yeah yeah
got it yeah i'm a big advocate of that
yeah um
i was just i'm curious if you thought
that that would have
uh an ability to affect like
presidential elections in a positive way
yes i do and i've been talking about
this for a long time
the combination of doing campaign
finance reform
and getting away from first past the
post towards something like single
transferable vote i think it would
it it it's impossible to overstate how
much it would do
it would allow third parties to really
have a shot
um it would make hopefully a lot of
americans kind of rethink how we
approach
elections i've been advocating for for
both of those things for a really long
time i think it would be great
um i'm kind of continuing um off of that
um do you think that
um that that would kind of hide like so
uh part of what i think is
currently wrong with the elections is
that um primaries sort of
allow for the most extreme candidate to
push through a lot of their um ideology
to
because most people who vote in
primaries are
either like uh highly engaged in the
situation
or um you know have um
more extreme um beliefs yeah i think
that allowed you know for
donald trump to sort of get um um
you know more um heinous uh i ideas out
there to
get support from the people who are more
engaged in the
in the in the primaries that may be more
true on the republican side i mean look
at the if you looked at the democratic
primary of 2020
the guy who had more support than we
thought was biden who was not the most
extreme candidate by any means in fact
to a fault he's completely
uncontroversial and not
extreme in any way so i don't know that
that's necessarily true at the national
level but it's certainly
plausible that in certain maybe within
the republican party
or in certain parts of the country it
might be true
do you think that might be a result of
the ways that um the democrats changed
their primary system
well tell me how you imagined that that
would be the case
um well in 2016 um there was a very
close race between
um clinton and um uh bernie and uh
there had been some changes that people
kind of were insinuating kind of
flattened some of that support so that
um it would allow the
um most um
popular uh candidate to kind of uh
take a charge over time yeah well so
i don't i don't know exactly what you're
referring to but the super delegates
voting on the first round at the
convention was
was eliminated in 2020 right so yeah i'm
just i'm just not sure about that but
all
important questions all right uh
i appreciate uh hearing from you and uh
you actually have some poor some some
support from uh
pennsylvania and pittsburgh you know i'm
most of that's uh
super red and super uh
problematic but uh you have some some
blue dots around there
all right thank you so much roman
appreciate the call
uh let's see who else we want to speak
to why don't we go
to oh i don't know maybe uh
maybe we go to trey from nashville trey
you're on the air
hey uh i wanted to ask you
and i'm not trying to drag you into this
really
ugly fight that we see going on on the
left right now
but i'm just not quite understanding
this whole dispute over
the syria chemical weapons attack that's
going on with like
the young turks and aaron mate and all
then i have no idea
i'm the wrong guy to ask i have
absolutely no idea
i think i think that the general thing
is they're
fighting over whether the 2018 chemical
attacks
like that allegedly assad did against
the people in syria whether it actually
happened
do you do you remember anything about
that uh
you know that attack and the reporting
that went to it i know that trump
responded by doing uh
air strikes on syria yeah my belief is
that it happened
uh but i have i am the last person to
weigh in i
i did a segment earlier this week about
the drama that's happening on the left
and i did talk about the
tyt jimmy dore stuff a little bit but
i couldn't tell you uh i don't know i
have no idea who
who is it that the young turks is
fighting with uh this guy aaron mate
he's a
he's a reporter he's done a lot of
reporting in uh
in syria okay yeah i have no idea what's
going on with them i'm sorry i'm just
not keeping up with it
okay cool one really different uh
sad question really quick um i just had
a
a a theory that i want to get your take
on
i'm gonna go ahead and say that in 2024
the gop they're gonna want to try to
take some kind of
identity politics appeal and on their
ticket they'll have
either a person of color or a woman
on the ticket so they can continue to
appeal to
uh the change in demographics do you
think that's possible yes
yes very much so yeah the right the
right loves to attack
identity politics and then play it and
yeah
so yeah that i would not be at all
surprised if that happened
yeah i'm just going to say you so this
is my way to early prediction so if it
happens 2024 we'll see but my guess
is tim scott is going to be the vp
nominee in 2024
okay all right let's let's check in in a
few years trey and see if you're right i
think that could be
yeah all right thank you man you have a
great day all right you too trey from
nashville great to hear from you let's
take a quick break if you are holding to
talk to me don't go anywhere because
we're going right back to the phones
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive of
every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount
join pacman.com all right let's hear for
a few
from a few more people via discord you
can find our discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's start off with
alfie from london you're on the air
oh hey david um i just had a quick
question um i'm not sure if this is
something you've really talked about
before
um mainly just sort of what your opinion
is
on um like euthanasia and the sort of
right to
the right to death in like medical
circumstances
i tend to be uh i tend to be pro
uh right to decide you don't want to
live
anymore and i do think that
you know because there can always be bad
actors in any system no matter what
safeguards we have i think we do want to
put in place
a system that would make it
if not impossible really difficult for
either
bad actor physicians or bad actor family
members or whatever to get involved in
ways that could be really bad but
i've generally been supportive of
euthanasia laws
okay yeah it's weird whenever i ask
someone about this they tend to
have some sort of variation on that they
seem like vaguely supportive
um but it just seems weird that in like
the uk and a lot of places in america
it's like
entirely illegal yeah um so i wonder
what if you think that will go anywhere
anytime soon
it doesn't feel at least at the federal
level like this is a big issue but it
doesn't necessarily need to be a big
issue at the federal level because
many of these decisions in the us are
made at the state level
so i think it will really depend on
state-level activists if they want to
um do more to try to move forward in
certain states on it but
it's not feeling right like right now in
the taking the pulse of the country
that it's a massive issue uh uh the
people that care about it care about it
a lot
i don't mean that there aren't people
who are very passionate about it but it
doesn't
feel like it's the biggest issue or
anywhere close to it right now
yeah definitely okay fair enough yeah
that was it thanks very much for taking
my call all right thanks very much
that's alfie from london
getting getting right to it which i love
why don't we try
next um oh i don't know
how about lilith from arizona lilith
from arizona you're on the air
uh hi hello
so i was really questioning because you
bring up quite often
about mass
i was deprogramming sorry i'm just a
little nervous never done this before
you're doing great but it does sound
like you're half the time covering your
phone with
something so make sure everything's
uncovered we want to hear you gotcha
all right well you're saying
that we need like uh like some sort of
nasty programming
yes right yeah i'm trying to figure out
like
how would we go about that i don't know
because
there's all this like anti-intellectual
right
i think we really need like an
intellectual revolution
per se okay and what would that look
like who would lead it
who would lead it you know that's a
that's a damn good question
did you have any ideas at all of who
would lead her
um i think it would have to be our youth
probably okay
so youth would do what in order to help
mask the program
you know that's that's what i was that's
you know i was calling in like a
question
because i don't have the answers yeah no
i don't either i mean you have the
kernel of a great idea
and i think the youth are the future in
a literal sense and a proverbial sense
so i think
young people should be involved in it uh
but i i just don't have the answer and
we talked recently
with andy norman a little bit about
masty programming and it is a tough
thing it is a very i don't have any
answers and it i don't know that we will
anytime soon
and something else i was thinking of is
maybe like you know a revolution of
empathy
i think i think that's something that
would be needed
you know for people to understand each
other and like really
try and like approach each other in like
a empathetic way
instead of like you know going like head
to head so much
well there's a partisan lack of empathy
in other words
there is less empathy on the right in
the brains of people on the right we
know that
and um that is that that alone but how
do you
how do you how do you convince people to
care about others right it's a really
tough thing
it has a lot to do with upbringing and
and predisposition and so many things
these are big complicated issues
right yeah yeah i don't know
it's it's too much honestly
yeah i wonder all right well thank you
for the call i appreciate it
yeah sorry no you're doing great thank
you great call great call great first
call to a program
um i'm sure the next one will be even
better
all right why don't we speak to a couple
of other people right i mean we're here
we sort of uh we sort of might as well
why don't we go to garen
from dallas
hey david can hear me yes i can
hey so um yes i'm a physician here in
dallas and i've just been you know been
listening to your show probably for the
past year and i've really appreciated
your
kind of rhetoric and take on the on the
uh just the whole coronavirus pandemic
in general
um i guess my my thoughts and my
questions to you is you know
you know as someone you know your family
kind of comes to your advice as a
physician you know and things like that
and
one of the things that's been really
kind of tough for me going forward as a
physician is well
you know i have this very pro vaccine
pro
uh you know masking standpoint and
people want to reach out to you and say
well
what about these other problems that i
have you know it's they kind of
i don't know if other physicians have
this kind of dilemma but it's trying
trying to
how do you how do you trust some
information that i tell you but not
other information that i tell you
and it's kind of broken the glass box
for me on a lot of people you know and
uh especially friends and family i'm
just curious if you've had that kind of
uh interactions or you're kind of those
revelations of certain people
it's like how can you not
understand this pretty good data that we
have you know it's
i don't know if you've had that kind of
experience i have i have family
now let me ask you this what's your
specialty
uh so i'm an orthopedic surgeon so okay
so it's not directly related to
immunology or epidemiology right so in
other words
people come to you and they say sir you
know my knees bothering me
and then you give them you you whatever
you talk about it
and then they implicitly trust you but
then when you say hey we
i'm a doctor i know how to read a
medical study get the vaccine
it's really effective all of a sudden
then they don't they don't believe you
they're skeptical of your your thought
that's uh yeah that's that you know all
these people become
pretty experts in the face of certain
data you know but then you know
obviously they
you know unequivocally trust my you know
input on their hip arthritis or you know
whatever you want to call it so sure
yeah it's it's just uh yeah you know i
don't know if other physicians or other
people have experienced that
you know they have i i know an emergency
um a pediatric emergency doctor
who has some anti-vaxx people floating
around in his family and he's talked
about how
they come to me with questions about
their babies and then all of a sudden
i'm saying we all need to get the
vaccine
and they it just doesn't convince them
they don't care
yeah hey listen while i have you on the
phone brief orthopedic consult
um so you know i'm in my mid
30s now and i'm getting a little bit of
sort of crunching crackling in my knees
and
when you google this it's everything
from you need a new leg
to don't worry about it right like how
should i be
thinking about that yeah so
you know i mean i mean you're in your
kind of mid-30s i think right so
you know everyone everyone kind of gets
arthritis as we age you know but there's
a ton of things that can cause knee pain
you know meniscal problems you know i
think you're
i've heard you say you're kind of an
avid runner and things like that
um so people
oh no we're losing you right at the key
moment of the diagnosis
oh oh yeah can you hear me yeah i'm
thinking you were saying running can
aggravate this
yeah i mean you know so it kind of
depends on your symptoms the crunching
popping things you're kind of describing
can sound like it could be meniscal
related or yeah
you know hopefully not early arthritis
for you but right probably not
so i actually have this birth defect
called
discoid meniscus in one knee and that's
uh that would probably
yeah that would probably be related to
some of the things you're referring to
is discoid meniscus typically bilateral
or it can be just on one side
you can definitely get it bilaterally um
but there are cases you know
unilaterally can be as well so i mean is
that the need that's popping on you
it's not that's the interesting thing
it's not well
you know some people when their kids
have discoid meniscus but
they never really bothers them you know
the main symptom they'll get is catching
symptoms
locking popping that kind of thing right
so some people have it and just never
really have pain so
if it's not bothering you then there's
really nothing much to do about it so
like
it is you know when you start to think
about it i'm like is my knee unstable am
i am i having a bigger issue here but it
might just be that i'm thinking about it
you know
yeah absolutely so for the most part i
can keep the leg for now
yeah i mean i don't think we're gonna
amputate it just yet on you
but uh you know let me know how it's
going and uh we can we can take it off
if we need to we'll take it from there
okay all right good okay
dr garen thank you so much thanks david
all right great call wow
uh and by the way if there's a
podiatrist in the audience i also have
other questions so if you could call in
i i would
really appreciate a consult on that as
well let's go
next to alvaro from
tulsa oklahoma you're on the air
alvaro
ooh just barely sounds like you're
underwater
ooh that's no it's no better yeah
all right gonna let him i mean it just i
just can't do that today it's too busy
of a day
to start with that um all right why
don't we try brenda from minnesota
brenda we've spoken before right
yep yes we have what's going on i have
been outed in chat as a boomer by the
way
oh very good thank you um
um so i wanted to ask you about there
was an incident that occurred a couple
days ago where
a um um a
bbc uh journalist was chased
and hounded by uh anti-massacres and
anti-vaxxers
yes i saw that this is really concerning
to me
because i kind of feel like these
conspiracy theories
can lead i mean acceptance of a
conspiracy
this can snowball really fast is my
concern
i think it's people this extreme are not
a problem
now but i think in the future it could
it could snowball really fast because
there is so much distrust of official
news sources these days
and then people have they just believe
whatever they read brenda i would go
further i think it's a problem
now and every the more i talk to
conspiracy experts the more they
say it doesn't matter if their most
prominent
wacky belief isn't that dangerous it
never
is an isolated belief there's always
more behind it there's either
racism or anti-semitism or other
conspiracies
um i think we can't take the approach of
and these people could be a problem down
the line if they transfer their wacky
beliefs to other areas i think we have
to see them as a problem now
well so then what is the solution and
i'm not familiar maybe i missed an
episode or something where you went
through
uh proposed solutions but no no no
there's been no episode on the solutions
i don't have them unfortunately
we can't just magic uh facts into
people's brains
no that that i we're still searching for
a solution we have a problem
we're searching for a solution i hope we
can find it that that would be
that would be an interesting show that i
would like to see yeah well i'm i'm
working on it i will i will
broadcast it as soon as i discover it
okay okay all right i think brenda thank
you
yes thank you very much bye-bye pleasure
great to speak to brenda again
that is all the time we have for today
if you didn't make it into today's show
fear not there will be another
opportunity
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
i received a ton of questions this week
since our coverage monday about
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu being out
and naftali bennett being in as prime
minister and the gist of the question
is will this actually make a difference
in terms of the israeli-palestinian
conflict and the answer is we just don't
know yet
there are folks who are claiming
that there is absolutely no difference
between naftali bennett and benjamin
netanyahu on their willingness to
make change to the status quo to it when
it comes to the israeli-palestinian
conflict and i think that there's
um some truth there's truth to the
reality that naftali bennett is still a
right winger there's no question about
that but
not from the party likud and a different
approach
and what you have to understand is that
a lot of what progress can be made comes
down to the coalition
the coalition which includes members of
multiple parties
agrees on some things and that's
typically where the vast majority of the
focus
focuses
and on areas where they disagree nothing
tends to happen
but the other side to this is that
no matter who you put in power in israel
if there is not some kind of coherent
change
coherent and productive change to
palestinian leadership nothing will
happen
there's just no chance uh whatsoever
i've been saying for years
a prerequisite for uh change
would be benjamin netanyahu not being
prime minister we've achieved that
okay we've got someone who's slightly
less right wing now
and might be willing to make some
changes and negotiate in some areas but
on the other hand you still have gaza
controlled by hamas
you have a palestinian authority in the
west bank that while
certainly more willing to work with
israel and there is a you know worker
program and there's there's much more
happening than with gaza
um is at odds in many ways
with hamas and um completely unwilling
uh hamas completely unwilling to
cede power to maybe allow the
palestinian authority to negotiate on
everyone's behalf i mean it's like
i sound crazy even talking about this
stuff because there's zero chance
that this is going to happen so i don't
know the answer and as i mentioned
earlier in the week
um the the vast majority of the israeli
population
is uh concerned with and
prioritizing domestic issues like
economics and wages and infrastructure
much like we do in the united states and
so
particularly as outsiders when we look
at
you know a place like ukraine and
for us one of the big issues we
associate with ukraine
is the conflict with russia and putin
versus ukraine and all of this stuff
for the vast majority of ukrainians
actually have a ukrainian friend who was
just just there and i said how much do
people talk about putin
says you know it's casual conversation
but the vast majority of it is
there's roads that are a disaster in
ukraine there's roads that are so
potholed
that it took four hours to go what on a
normal road would take
half an hour in order to get to the the
village that he was originally from
that's what people there care about and
this is one of the great distortions you
know people talk about the distortion
of following foreign policy um
of well you take on the biases
of whatever the media in your country
has
and much of the american left likes to
say almost all american media is biased
pro-israel the real bias
is that we end up thinking that the big
issues domestically
are the israeli-palestinian conflict
when they are not
and similarly based on what we hear
about ukraine
we might think everybody's constantly
talking about the the situation with
putin another example i've spoken to
korean friends
who are they live in the united states
but have family
in south korea and for example
at a moment when there was a big
flare-up with missile launches from
kim jong-un and i said oh how's your
family thinking about or dealing with
the rocket launches
and he said you know it's r it really if
you're right there
and have reason to think that you may be
in danger it's something that might be
on your
radar so to speak but for his family
it wasn't really an issue it was jobs it
was health care it was
globalization and and so many other
things and so the real cognitive
distortion that happens
as americans following uh the politics
of other countries is we tend to focus
only on the things that are externally
facing and maybe relate to us in some
way which is logical
because hey we're us and that's in some
sense what we care about
um but the the internal situation is
often much different so
needless to say i think that there is
five to seven percent greater
possibility
that we start to see some serious uh
negotiations
when it comes to the israeli-palestinian
conflict but if and until there's
a leadership change in gaza i just don't
see how
anything is going to change if you have
a different view let me know
hey david what would happen if you
abolished the minimum wage
okay so the this there's been a lot of
talk about a 15
minimum wage lately and we learned last
week that chipotle
in order to account for paying 15 bucks
an hour is raising prices four percent
which is a really really modest
increase it's like 26 cents on your
average chicken burrito
uh even though everybody will earn 15 an
hour
and there are some sort of libertarian
right wing types who say
listen the the minimum wage is an
artificial price floor
and it um is simply
a bad it's a price control it's bad for
the economy
it keeps people out of the workforce if
you eliminated the minimum wage
sure wages might come down a little bit
but way more people
would end up becoming employed and that
would be good for the economy because
then they would pay taxes and
okay first of all if you
saw a decrease to the minimum wage
that's
significant and it led to more
employment a lot of those people because
the wage would be so low
would would not or would barely pay any
federal taxes so in
in reality the tax thing may even be
be wrong number one number two
we have a counter example to this okay
the value of the minimum wage remember
if you have a seven dollar minimum wage
and you have inflation
the value of that minimum wage actually
goes down
if you're the employer and there is
inflation meaning your product or
service sells for more
but you pay the same nominal minimum
wage you are actually
seeing a decrease to the minimum wage in
real terms
we had a situation in the 1980s
where the minimum wage the the actual
value of the minimum wage went down
about a third because of inflation
and we actually saw teen employment
drop site slightly this is the big claim
from the right
all of these teenagers and entry-level
workers and what we call
less skilled workers they would have way
more employment
if the minimum wage were to go down well
the minimum wage
did go down in real terms during the
1980s and significantly so just under a
third
32 i believe the number is and you did
not see teen employment explode because
it all of a sudden became
really cheap to hire people it got
cheaper for businesses to hire
because of that stagnant minimum wage
and they didn't and as i've said so many
times before when it comes to taxation
and hiring and the minimum wage if a
business
is understaffed relative to the demand
for their product or service
then it would make sense to go and add a
new worker
and if you can get that worker for less
well okay
even better for the business i guess but
it's not
profitable to just add workers because
it's cheaper to add them it doesn't make
sense
think about it you know with the david
pakman show
if we actually have a an unmet need
either because we have so much demand
for
advertising that i need more sales
people
or we have so much demand for
memberships that i need
to bring on a full-time web developer to
keep up with the website traffic or
whatever the case may be
just because it becomes cheaper to hire
someone doesn't mean i'm actually going
to go and hire someone unless i'm
servicing demand now
what would actually increase demand and
this is where the right just kind of
seems to
not not get it or pretend not to get it
what would increase demand for
memberships
it would be people having more money and
one way
to put more money in the pockets of
people
who might only borderline be able to
afford a membership right now
would be a minimum wage increase now i
think there are
some fair assessments about the minimum
wage that come from the right one is
most people don't make minimum wage and
because wages tend to be sticky wages
don't tend to come down
if you got rid of the minimum wage it's
unlikely that most people's wages
would come down if you're in a job where
you make the equivalent of 25 bucks an
hour it might be 25 bucks an hour or it
might just be a 50
000 a year salary right um if the
minimum wage
went down or even was eliminated it's
not hugely likely
at least right away that you would end
up earning less money
but there is a particularly vulnerable
class of workers
particularly when we're talking about
immigrants
talking about people in disadvantaged
uh neighborhoods that already often have
the sort of structural disadvantages of
terrible public transit and so on and so
forth
those are the first folks who are going
to be uh taken advantage of and there's
going to be this downward pressure
and the the whole point of the minimum
wage
is not to ensure everybody makes 50
grand a year
that would require a 25 minimum wage at
every job
in many states that are low cost of
living that's not it's just not an
equilibrium wage
and i know there's many people who say
the minimum wage should be 25 bucks an
hour
you know in rural alabama a 25 an hour
minimum wage is out of equilibrium
with business profitability and cost of
living in some
big cities that probably is the right
minimum wage but the point here is
uh you are going to see uh the most
disadvantaged than those with the least
market power to advocate for themselves
taken advantage of now the right will
then come back in and say well
they can then organize and they can all
agree
we're not going to work for less than x
and they can push prices up and demand
to be paid more
that's what unions do now and those same
right wingers are against unions and
they're against collective bargaining
and on and on and on so
you really have to step back from the
talking points on this
if you eliminate the minimum wage is it
likely that a lot of people would start
working for 50 cents an hour
no that's not likely but the federal
minimum wage is already
pathetic uh and uh what you
the the other thing by the way that's
important to remember is reducing the
minimum wage
will shift the burden of paying people
away from businesses and towards the
government if you reduce the minimum
wage you're also basically setting up
a a bigger government handout and
subsidy because
the benefits and welfare programs that
individuals will start to qualify for
if you scrap the minimum wage and you
see somewhat of a reduction
you know 725 maybe some people start
working for six or five dollars an hour
or 450 or whatever
um the the fact that more people will
work which
doesn't appear to be true but even if it
were true more people will work if you
reduce the minimum wage
they whatever they pay in to the
government
you will lose because they will qualify
for a government welfare programs
that cost the government money that come
out of taxes anyway so
the point of the minimum wage is let's
agree and establish some minimum
that makes sense based on cost of living
based on equilibrium wages based on what
we consider to
to be um a a reasonable standard to set
we're not talking about a 50
an hour 100 an hour minimum wage and it
should be in balance
with the broader economy and prevent the
most vulnerable from being taken
advantage of that's really the point
and the hypothesis about well if more
money is good pay people a hundred bucks
or if you get rid of the minimum wage
people will be working for 10 cents an
hour
you're focusing on these the extremes
and you're really sort of missing the
big picture
david if covid really was created in a
lab
what would be the repercussions well the
the
i assume that you mean created in a lab
by china obviously if the if the virus
was created
in a lab by you know eritrea
the consequences would be very different
than china the focus has been on
china i think with the lab league stuff
there's a few different
um parameters and ways that that could
shake out
number one if it was literally created
in a lab as a bio weapon and
deliberately released
first of all it's really stupid because
of how many people died in china and it
also in a sense is a failed bio weapon
because the death rate is comparatively
low if if you really wanted to do damage
and do bio terror you would
probably develop something that had more
than
you know like the 0.7 death rate that
kovid
has uh but that's sort of like an aside
it would have been a really stupid thing
anyway because if those who believe it
was done as a bio weapon believe it was
done to attack the us
it mostly killed people outside the
united states it didn't even
really [ __ ] [ __ ] economies i mean
some countries handled it better than
others but
the economic recovery recovery is going
relatively well so
if that's the case it was really dumb
and poorly executed
but it would have significant foreign
policy impacts if if
if we learned that this was a bio weapon
deliberately released by china
i'm not saying war but it would be
certainly economic war
i believe that that's the least likely
scenario when you look at lab leak
conspiracies
the next scenario would be that
it was being studied in a lab
and it accidentally was released someone
scratched themselves and then it went
out into the
public if that's the case i think there
are going to be
economic sanctions i think it's going to
be taken very seriously i think there
there will be consequences but it's not
going to be of the scale
that those who are clamoring for the it
was a bio weapon uh conspiracy
are uh sort of pointing to and
then you know if if it was the the most
likely scenario to me still is
it emerged naturally in china it
may have been studied in a lab
but the spread did not originate at that
lab
and china pretty clearly covered it up
early
we covered the story i believe it was in
december of 2019 of one of the uh
doctors who was saying hey this is going
on this is going on and police came to
his house and said don't talk about this
anymore
um and china understated the number of
cases and china understated the number
of deaths
i don't know what the consequences
should be in that case but you're you're
then talking about
a diplomatic issue that is far different
than the other extreme which is this was
a created bio weapon deliberately
released um as you can tell
you know i tend to think that the
reality comes in sort of those latter
examples as i've always said before
it should all be looked into there is no
investigation
or analysis that should not be done i'm
for all of the investigations
but i think we should be careful not to
say
that something is likely until we really
know for sure and right now we can't say
any of these lab leaks
are likely if you have a different view
let me know we have a great bonus show
for you today
sign up at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman